consultant dissociate professional  there's so much confusion around job  tired it's inconsisting in the end of  the day it's very simple the only three  main roads that you will have in a  consulting firm you are either a simple  consultant and as such you're  responsible for one part of a project in  this thing module or you can be a  project lead managing usually one to  four consultants in the strategy firm is  responsible for one complete project or  you are a partner managing different  projects next to each other independent  from job titles you can always assign  yourself to one of these three roles in  consulting projects